aujourd'hui je vais vous parler
d'histoire
mais comme j'ai un ego assez développé
je vais d'abord vous parler de mon
histoire
quand j'étais petit je regardais souvent
le ciel et les étoiles en me demandant
de quelle planète je pouvais bien venir
je me sentais extrêmement différentes
j'avais l'impression d'être une
extraterrestre et je détestais ça
je souffrais énormément du regard des
autres alors j'ai étudié le
fonctionnement des humains comme une
ethnologue pour pouvoir leur ressembler
et me fondre dans la masse
j'ai fait tout ce que je pouvais pour
être la plus normale possible
personne ne savait réellement qui
j'étais je me montrais seulement quand
j'étais capable de compenser ma
différence pour passer inaperçu
je croyais que si je me montrais tels
que j'étais je n'aurais pas d'avenir et
c'est finalement cette croyance là qui a
failli me tuer
tout ça m'épuise et j'étais de plus en
plus déprimé et mal dans ma peau et
surtout j'étais en train de me perdre
totalement moyenne
et à force de me renier et de mesures
adaptées j'ai fini par faire un gros
burn out
mais je me souviens du jour où j'ai
vraiment touché le fond
j'étais hospitalisée en psychiatrie
depuis des mois j'étais désespéré je me
demandais chaque jour car tout ça allait
enfin s'arrêter je ne voyais plus
l'intérêt de me soigner d'une en sortir
mais ce jour-là ce vendredi 10 juin 2018
je me suis prise pour martin luther king
et j'ai eu un rêve
j'ai rêvé de pouvoir vivre dans un monde
où on a le droit d'être différent
j'ai rêvé de pouvoir créer un projet qui
me servirait à mettre mon expérience à
profit pour aider les personnes à
s'accepter à aimer leurs différences à
dépasser leurs difficultés et à faire de
leurs particularités une force
alors j'ai pris un cahier super beau et
des stylos de plein de couleurs
différentes et j'ai commencé à noter
toutes les idées qui me passait par la
tête pour mon projet
j'ai alterné le travail thérapeutique et
le travail sur mon projet et plus
j'avançais sur ce projet mieux je me
sentais j'avais un pourquoi une
motivation une raison de m'en sortir qui
étaient connectés à quelque chose de
tellement important pour moi que mes
soucis avec le regard des autres étaient
déjà bien
je me suis reconnecter à monein et j'ai
appris à me connaître
je me suis enfin accepté
et j'ai commencé à vivre en accord avec
moi-même j'étais persuadé de me
retrouver seule mais je préfèrerais
encore être rejetée par le monde entier
que continuer à me renier davantage
mais à ma grande surprise mes relations
avec les autres sont devenus de plus en
plus facile
j'ai cherché à comprendre pourquoi et
j'ai repensé à cette phrase que l'on
connaît tous
on ne peut pas plaire à tout le monde
et cette phrase je l' ai vu autrement
et je pense que si on est d'accord pour
dire qu'on ne peut pas plaire à tout le
monde savait aussi forcément dire qu'on
ne peut pas non plus des plaire à tout
le monde alors c'est génial on ne peut
pas déplaire à tout le monde
soyons nous mêmes
ça nous permettra d'attirer à nous des
personnes qui nous corresponde vraiment
avec qui on se sent bien et de pouvoir
nouer des relations profondes et
sincères
personnellement m'accepter m'a permis de
rencontrer mon associé avec qui c'est un
réel plaisir de partager un projet
commun autour d'un thème qui nous tient
à coeur
pour mettre à profit mon expérience je
me suis formé au développement personnel
au coaching et à l'art thérapie
ça me permet aujourd'hui d'aider les
personnes que j'accompagne à s'aimer à
accepter leurs différences à dépasser
leurs difficultés et à faire de leurs
particularités une force qui peut
importer au plus grand nombre
le fait d'avoir dû analyser en
permanence mon environnement et le
comportement des gens
me permet aujourd'hui de mieux
comprendre les personnes de trouver
facilement leurs points forts leur
particularité est ce qu'elles peuvent en
faire en fonction de leur tempérament
et finalement le fait de voir le monde
d'une façon différente ma porte souvent
des solutions originales aux
problématiques
mais ce qui me plaît par dessus tout
c'est de transformer mon histoire de
façon positive
et d'en faire quelque chose qui peut
apporter aux autres et à l'histoire
parce que chacune de nos petites
histoires personnelles façonne
l'histoire de l'humanité en acceptant
d'être différent et de se comporter
différemment on peut chacun à notre
niveau influencé le cours de l'histoire
alors soyons tous des petits martin
luther king parlons de nos rêves et du
monde dans lequel on voudrait vivre
et servons nous de nos histoires
personnelles pour écrire l'histoire de
demain
et toi alors que vas tu faire de ton
histoire